the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns video in
this video I will be discussing some of
the recent news surrounding Game of
Thrones showrunners David and Dan
scheduled appearance at Comic Con some
of you may or may not know this but they
were scheduled to sit on one of the
panels at comic-con in San Diego today
when this news was released a few weeks
ago there was a big reaction from within
the game of Thrones and the isang of Ice
and Fire community the writers David and
Dan do not often sit down for interviews
so when the fans found out they would be
attending this sent the internet into a
frenzy as you all know the ending a game
of Thrones basically shattered this
fandom many fans did enjoy it for what
it was but it's no secret most of us
were sitting there scratching our heads
wondering why the writers decided to
make some of the decisions we saw on the
screen before the final season was even
over there were already hundreds and
maybe even thousands of different videos
in articles taken shots directly at the
show runners who weren't responsible for
most of the bad writing at the end well
just when it looked like some fans might
get a chance to ask the writers about
some of their decisions some more news
came out which revealed they're no
longer gonna be attending Comic Con
Entertainment Weekly always seems to
have the exclusive access to any and
everything Game of Thrones related so
let's go ahead and see what they said
about these recent developments The Game
of Thrones show runners are not going to
comic-con after all HBO revealed
Wednesday an updated panel lineup for
the upcoming San Diego fan event with
five previously announced names no
longer scheduled to attend writers and
producers David Benioff and Dan Weiss
director Miguel support snake and a few
of the actors are no longer going still
scheduled to attend the panel Jacob
Anderson John Bradley Nikolaj
coster-waldau liam Cunningham Conleth
Hill Maisie Williams and Isaac Hempstead
right this move comes on the heels the
Game of Thrones receiving a historic 32
Emmy nominations for the final season on
Tuesday which do include nominations for
Benioff
and Weiss for writing the series finale
the Iron Throne and support for
directing the Winterfell battle episode
the long night comic-con was expected to
be the first public appearance or
interview by the Game of Thrones
showrunner since the divisive series
finale aired back in May no reason was
given for the schedule change appearing
at another fan convention
konna Thrones last weekend Star
coster-waldau brought up viewer reaction
as it pertains to the show's writers for
anyone to imagine or to think that the
two creators of the show are not the
most passionate the greatest and most
invested of all and to for a second
think that they did not spend the last
10 years thinking about how they were
going to end it as kind of silly and
also know that they to read the comments
and it is even though you sit there on
your own and go effing stupid writers
a-holes they really like everyone on
Game of Thrones every single person and
there are thousands we worked our asses
off to make the best show we could for
the ending during the Q&A portion a fan
said how much the show meant to him in
the actor added I just wish that Dan and
Dave could be here to hear this to
understand that people really do love
the show that suddenly they're not the
most hated people in the world I mean
because that's how they might I know
that's how they feel so after reading
what Nikolaj said it is obvious that Dan
and Dave are well aware of how the fans
feel after the finale the backlash from
the final season was unavoidable the
fans were not just talking about it
online but even some of the late night
shows were discussing the negative
reactions about how Game of Thrones
ended let's go ahead and see what some
of the fans already have to say about
them backing out of the event Richard
says shocker oh wait no it's not never
expected them to show up anyway maybe if
they buried their heads in the sand and
hide away long enough the angry fans
will forget how much they are pissed off
at these two now that's not gonna happen
the next one says cowards
you made it sustained by it they're
scared of questions like so what
happened to all the azure high stuff or
please explain in detail how bran
who wasn't in a whole season had the
best story or why did arias spend so
much time at the house of black and
white for her faceless main abilities to
be mostly irrelevant to the pawn or how
does a woman on a dragon get surprised
by a fleet of ships she should have
easily seen they have fast the final
season
they cannot admit it that's not only the
actors who did the best they could given
the material not on HBO who offered them
more episodes and not on Martin I do
imagine that a lot of the big moments
are going to be in the books but they're
gonna be executed much better because
Martin is Martin it's all on them and
they should be ashamed greatest show of
all time ruined at the very end by I
don't know if it's laziness hubris and
competence or a mix of all three Sandra
Dee says they don't know unhappy viewers
myself included anything why would
anyone want to stand by and get beat up
for self entitled crying fans it's time
to move on I'm not happy with the last
season at all I'll just wait for the
last two books and hope it's a more
satisfactory ending either way Dave and
Dan will not be there to give any of the
fans some answers as most of you already
know I'm not the one who typically makes
videos bashing the writers for the
mistakes they've made but I do have to
say I agree with most of what was said
from these other fans I do happen to
think they are avoiding the elephant in
the room they know a big section of the
community are not happy with them right
now and they're not ready to face all
the negativity that followed what should
have been the greatest ending in
television history now like I said I'm
not as upset as some of you may be but I
would love to see what they have to say
about certain decisions they made
unfortunately it might be a very long
time before they open themselves up for
an interview about the final season as
you can see by the article from
Entertainment Weekly they did not give a
reason for why they decided to back out
at the last minute but I think most of
us can guess why I would be interested
in hearing what some of you have to say
about the recent update now maybe you
weren't even aware of this at all but
let me know what you think made them
change their mind
leave me some of your thoughts down
below anyways thanks for stopping by and
supporting the channel I hope all of you
have a great day I'll see you again very
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]